congratulations graduates it is my
deepest honor to join you here your
commencement from one of the greatest
universities in the world yes and still
the only institution in America where
you might overhear someone ask a man
what are you wearing under that skirt to
which he might reply
stuck in the bottom of a hole in the
most remote desert in the entire United
States I actually turned to the
analytical problem-solving skills that I
had forged here at CMU it's not
hyperbole step one define the problem
well okay that was the easy part I'm
dead there was this big rock my next
steps were to gather information
brainstorm solutions prioritize them and
try one by this iterative process I
refined my experience through day after
day of struggle it's in that final
moment I stepped out of my grave and
into my life whatever you can do
whatever you can do or dream you can do
beginning boldness has genius magic and
power in it yes it hurt yes I left
something behind but I did not lose
anything that day I only gained from
that experience a sense of what's
important to me of what's possible for
me of what's extraordinary in me and as
for that guarantee it's true you will
have adversity but be grateful for it
because that adversity will show you
that there is something absolutely
extraordinary in each and every one of
you and may your boulders be your
blessings as well thank you
you